his where it begins we've been looking
at recurrence relations right and
recurrence relations thankfully for you
you'll generally be told when you when
you have to search for one but as
mathematician when you look at something
like what would signal to you who a
recurrence relation would be useful in
the cortex like this yeah okay fantastic
as a part of this where you like but
what to do with this like I don't
actually know what that number is and it
sort of indicates to me that if I use
integration by parts if part of this is
differentiated then this part by using
chain rule here it's going to climb down
to n minus 1 and then that's going to
climb through n minus 2 and so on and
the recurrence relation will begin okay
so the first part is just to get the
recurrence relation that's all we're
trying to do and do know this up this
restriction he'd remember I said to you
before depending on the kind of function
you've got right that the kind of
integrated you've got the your whatever
Eddie is sometimes has restrictions on
you can see if I allow on an equal 0 as
a case right what would that integral be
it be the integral from 1 not 2 1 off it
would be x times 1 this is power 0 all
right it's not exit 0 it's aimed at 0
and with respect to X now that's the
integral of x DX this is clearly in a
different remember sort of your families
of integrators right and it's like the
same family anymore this little log X
term so you'd expect it to be something
very very different okay so that's going
to play it in for us later we need to
pay attention to that secondly which is
about you Aquinas evaluating records for
everybody because you'll notice what's a
different thing different feature for
what we've looked at before is that this
is a definite integral so I have
boundaries here okay now don't forget
because so far all we understand if
recurrence relations is built on an
excuse me integration by parts when
you've got this bit right the integral
of U DV key credit for me
it was you they take away in triple of
me to you and I did allude to you before
if you've got boundaries here it here
then we kind of expect a lien it must be
memories here and here as well but there
are other boundaries hiding where are
they yeah this is the sky which has been
integrated so therefore it needs to be
in a way ok so that's good was it fun so
let's he'll go at this we're going to
begin by thinking about well integration
by parts what would you like to try I'm
looking for you which will give me do
you and I looking for DV which will give
me v suggestions we always like when we
have power n minus 1 ok yes and oh I
feel like we did do another example
where we didn't have to do that now when
you have a look at this do we do we have
to have in for example one of the ones
we looked at was this guy actually I
think I did cause when you first we
looked at this ok and the reason we had
to split it up is because integration by
parts requires a product doesn't it to
make it work ok without doing any
splitting of the power I already have a
product yeah i mean i could split it
further if I wanted to is good well
there's an N minus 1 well hint number of
ways are splitting up this product but
sale you this one yes it does it does so
there's a one here and this is quite
cause n to the end or I couldn't say i
which i think i did i could take out a
cos x which these view the cars and
minus one x ok so that gives me some
options but when i look at this I'm not
pushed to that sort of requirement
because I already have a product beer
and maybe that will be useful for me
maybe it won't but why don't we give it
a shot ok now remembering that when we
selects the the pieces right what if it
gets differentiated and so hopefully
that's the part that gets successively
better that's like a translation and
then there's a part that gets integrated
and you don't want to cause like a
disaster there right so which of these
do you think is the one that you
to frigid and which is the only one i
integrate the other indexes appreciators
integrated Beckett okay very good I mean
in some ways the first thing you think
about is I don't really know today that
if I were to try and integrate ok so
that's one easy way of thinking I think
that's a candidate for differentiation
so I'm go ahead and differentiate that
now if I do the outside first its just
something to a power so I'm going to
bring the power down the front reduce
the power by one that was the outside
now I should do the inside which is one
onyx so I'm just gonna write that like
so I could write a little expert you'll
see it's going to cancel little bit of
pity okay we chose you now I guess that
leaves this for TV which means that the
waiting room will be excellent okay now
this is promising this is promising
because what you have a look at I keep
on calling at this when you have a look
at your green how her right um it's
still a bit gross but actually it kind
of exactly what we expect for a
recurrence relation yeah I'm expecting
something that looks like this except
where the power that's reduced by one
tick okay and then there are some
constants I'm gonna have to deal with so
that time let's write this line